This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In February 1945, as World War II was nearing its end in Europe, the leaders of the three major Allied powers, the United States, Britain, and the Soviet Union, met at the Yalta Conference in Crimea to discuss the terms of Germany's surrender. The Soviet premier, Joseph Stalin, wanted Germany to pay $20 billion in reparations, the equivalent of $333 billion in today's money. Such a demand would almost certainly have caused economic collapse in Germany. This seemed to be Joseph Stalin's goal—destroy Germany to ensure it could never rise again
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。1945年2月，随着第二次世界大战在欧洲接近尾声，三大盟国——美国、英国和苏联的领导人在克里米亚的雅尔塔会议上会晤，讨论德国投降的条件。苏联总理约瑟夫·斯大林希望德国支付200亿美元的赔款，相当于今天货币的3330亿美元。这样的要求几乎肯定会导致德国经济崩溃。这似乎正是斯大林的目标——摧毁德国，以确保它永远无法再崛起
as a threat. In his eyes, Nazi Germany had more than earned such punishment. The Western Allies were against this approach. They were not interested in punishing Germany. The war was almost over. They saw how the punitive terms imposed on Germany after World War I had backfired, leading to the rise of Adolf Hitler and the Nazis.
成为一种威胁。在他看来，纳粹德国所受的惩罚还远远不够。西方盟国反对这种做法。他们对惩罚德国不感兴趣。战争即将结束。他们看到了第一次世界大战后强加给德国的惩罚性条款是如何适得其反的，并导致了阿道夫·希特勒和纳粹的崛起。
The United States and Britain wanted to focus on Europe's long-term stability, rather than look backwards at the death and destruction that Germany had caused. Today on the show, we examine these conflicting impulses. We've all heard the phrase, an eye for an eye, a tooth for a tooth. The idea is simple. When someone commits a terrible act, they should pay an equally terrible price. It feels fair. It feels just.
美国和英国希望关注欧洲的长期稳定，而不是回顾德国造成的死亡和破坏。今天在节目中，我们将探讨这些相互冲突的冲动。我们都听过“以眼还眼，以牙还牙”这句话。这个想法很简单。当某人犯下可怕的罪行时，他们应该付出同样可怕的代价。这感觉很公平。这感觉很正义。
But does it always make sense? For them? For us? This week on Hidden Brain, we examine the psychology of revenge. What causes people to prioritize the destruction of others, even if it risks destruction for themselves? You've certainly been wronged at various points in your life. What did you do about it? How long did it take you to get over it? Some transgressions are easy to forget.
但这总是合理的吗？对他们来说？对我们来说？本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将探讨复仇的心理学。是什么导致人们优先考虑摧毁他人，即使这会冒着毁灭自己的风险？你肯定在人生的不同阶段受到过不公正的对待。你是怎么处理的？你花了多长时间才走出来？有些冒犯很容易被遗忘。
Others can linger for decades. At Yale University's Department of Psychiatry, James Kimmel Jr. studies how people respond when they are wronged and ways to align our thirst for revenge with our values and long-term interests. James Kimmel, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shakaar. It's an honor to be here. James on May 25, 1993, a man named Michael Stokes walked into a crowded fast food restaurant
另一些则可能持续数十年。在耶鲁大学精神病学系，詹姆斯·金梅尔（James Kimmel Jr.）研究人们在受到不公正对待时的反应，以及如何将我们的复仇渴望与我们的价值观和长期利益相协调。詹姆斯·金梅尔，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，尚卡尔。很荣幸来到这里。詹姆斯，1993年5月25日，一个名叫迈克尔·斯托克斯（Michael Stokes）的男子走进了一家拥挤的快餐店
in Connecticut with a handgun. Who was he and what did he do? Michael was a Navy cook on leave that day and he entered the restaurant with a specific goal of finding a woman that he had an infatuation with named Wanda and a man that he believed she had been seeing on the side named William. When he located them at the back of the restaurant, he executed them both. So I understand that Michael Stokes pled guilty to two counts of murder. He is currently serving a 55-year sentence in a maximum security prison in Connecticut. Did he have a history of violent crime before this incident, James?
手里拿着一把手枪。他是谁，他做了什么？迈克尔那天是一名休假的海军厨师，他进入餐厅时有一个明确的目标，那就是找到一个他迷恋的叫旺达（Wanda）的女人，以及一个他认为她私下交往的叫威廉（William）的男人。当他在餐厅后面找到他们时，他处决了他们两人。所以我了解到迈克尔·斯托克斯承认了两项谋杀罪。他目前正在康涅狄格州的一所最高安全级别的监狱服刑55年。詹姆斯，在这起事件之前，他有暴力犯罪史吗？
No, zero. He was actually quite a peaceful young man in school and as a young adult. Tell me about his background. How did he come to be in the restaurant that day? What was the story, James? Yeah, sure. So he and his brother were students at a Connecticut high school.
没有，完全没有。事实上，他在学校和成年早期是一个相当平和的年轻人。跟我说说他的背景。他那天是怎么来到那家餐厅的？故事是什么，詹姆斯？是的，当然。他和他的兄弟曾是康涅狄格州一所高中的学生。
He had a great deal of popularity, but he always felt like an outsider. He struggled, though, academically in school. And he was admitted to the University of Connecticut, but unfortunately flunked out in his first semester. He began doing small jobs and eventually got a job at this restaurant as a fast food cook. And at this restaurant he meets this woman named Wanda. Tell me about her. Who was she and what was the connection between them? Yeah, Wanda was a co-worker in the restaurant and Michael explains to me that he was immediately attracted to her. Unfortunately, she was also married at the time, but even so they were able to begin to create a relationship, a platonic one, but one that involved going to movies and shopping
他非常受欢迎，但他总是觉得自己像个局外人。不过，他在学校的学业很吃力。他被康涅狄格大学录取，但不幸的是，他在第一学期就挂科退学了。他开始做些零工，最终在这家餐厅找到了一份快餐厨师的工作。就在这家餐厅，他遇到了这个叫旺达的女人。跟我说说她。她是谁，他们之间有什么联系？是的，旺达是餐厅的同事，迈克尔向我解释说，他立刻被她吸引了。不幸的是，她当时也结婚了，但即便如此，他们还是能够开始建立一种关系，一种柏拉图式的关系，但这种关系包括一起去看电影、一起购物
together, going out to eat together, all with the consent of her husband, at least as she related it to Michael. And Michael began to fall in love with her. He became quite infatuated with her and really began hoping that maybe at some point he'd be able to have the relationship with her that he desperately wanted. So after some time, Wanda took a job as a manager at a different restaurant. Tell me what happened next. Well, Michael continued pursuing her at the new restaurant, but Wanda refused to reply. She essentially dropped all communications with Michael, and this frustrated and upset
一起出去吃饭，所有这些都是在她丈夫同意的情况下进行的，至少她是这样向迈克尔描述的。迈克尔开始爱上她。他变得非常迷恋她，并真的开始希望在某个时候，他能和她建立他梦寐以求的关系。所以过了一段时间，旺达在另一家餐厅找了一份经理的工作。告诉我接下来发生了什么。嗯，迈克尔继续在那家新餐厅追求她，但旺达拒绝回应。她基本上切断了与迈克尔的所有联系，这让他感到非常沮丧和难过
him greatly because he wanted to continue that relationship. And Michael began to hear rumors that Wanda was having an affair with a different employee at that restaurant. So Michael spends a brief stint in the Navy. He goes through basic training. He's transferred eventually back to Connecticut.
因为他想继续那种关系。迈克尔开始听到传言说旺达正在和那家餐厅的另一名员工有染。所以迈克尔在海军服役了一小段时间。他完成了基础训练。最终他被调回了康涅狄格州。
He reaches out and back to Connecticut. He reaches out and tries to make connection with Wanda again. Pick up the story. What happens then, James? He reaches out to her again and again, she continues to rebuff him and not communicate with him until one night she contacts him and says that she's lost her husband or is unable to find him and asks if Michael would be willing to help drive her around and locate him. And he agrees to do this. They locate Wanda's husband. Michael waits for Wanda and her husband to have some conversation and then Wanda comes back. Michael drives her home, leaves her there. But his expectation at this point was that he had done all of these kind things for her. He had been faithful to her and
他联系并回到了康涅狄格州。他联系并试图再次与旺达建立联系。接着讲这个故事。然后发生了什么，詹姆斯？他一次又一次地联系她，她继续拒绝他，不与他交流，直到有一天晚上她联系他，说她失去了丈夫或者找不到他，并问迈克尔是否愿意帮忙开车带她四处寻找。他同意了。他们找到了旺达的丈夫。迈克尔等着旺达和她丈夫交谈，然后旺达回来了。迈克尔开车送她回家，把她留在那里。但他此时的期望是，他为她做了所有这些善意的事情。他一直对她忠诚，并且
was truly willing and expressed that he would be her knight in shining armor whenever she needed it. And he was hoping that this would result in a relationship with her. And did it? It did not. Soon after that event began, she ceased all communication again. And that was the kind of the final mark for Michael and the final spiral, spiraling moment because he had kind of bet everything on a relationship with her. He had seen so much failure in his life and he needed a win and the win that he was hoping for was Wanda. And when that didn't occur, he began this downward spiral into what he describes as depression and anger and rage and at one eventually he becomes a Suicide or he begins to think of thoughts of killing himself We don't know how all this unfolded from one does perspective
确实愿意并表示，无论何时她需要，他都会成为她的白马王子。他希望这能带来一段与她的关系。结果呢？并没有。在那件事发生后不久，她再次停止了所有交流。这对迈克尔来说是最后的标志，也是最后螺旋式下降的时刻，因为他几乎把一切都押在了与她的关系上。他在生活中经历了太多的失败，他需要一次胜利，而他所希望的胜利就是旺达。当这一切没有发生时，他开始陷入他所描述的抑郁、愤怒和狂怒之中，最终他变得想要自杀，或者开始产生杀掉自己的念头。我们不知道这一切从旺达的角度是如何展开的。
Many women know all too well the anxiety and fear that can arise when they decline a man's advances And he won't take no for an answer What we do know is what Michael did next. He went out and purchased two handguns. Yeah I think that at first his thoughts were rage and anger towards himself for you know not being able to find success in any part of his life but as, as this continued to spiral, he eventually came to a point where he decided that the next day he would kill himself and he saw no other way out. So he was really disappointed in himself at this point. But that next day when he woke up with the plan to kill himself, he had a different thought and when he began to imagine what it would be like
许多女性太了解当她们拒绝男人的追求而男人不接受拒绝时所产生的焦虑和恐惧。我们所知道的是迈克尔接下来做了什么。他出去买了把手枪。是的，我想起初他的想法是对自己感到愤怒和狂怒，因为你知道，他在生活的任何方面都无法取得成功，但随着这种情况继续恶化，他最终到了一个地步，决定第二天就自杀，他看不到其他出路。所以他当时对自己真的很失望。但第二天，当他带着自杀的计划醒来时，他有了不同的想法，当他开始想象那会是什么样子
to kill himself, he imagined how Wanda and the man that Michael believed he was having an affair with, how they would react to news of his death. And as he saw this in his mind's eye, he saw them laughing and just mocking his weakness and kind of celebrating that he was gone. And those thoughts, which were purely inside his head and completely made up, but they became more and more real for him. And as they did, his anger and rage toward Wanda and what Michael considered to be her unfaithfulness
自杀时，他想象旺达和那个迈克尔认为她有染的男人会如何对他的死讯做出反应。当他在脑海中看到这一幕时，他看到他们在嘲笑他的软弱，并庆祝他的离去。而那些想法，完全是他脑子里的，完全是编造的，但对他来说却变得越来越真实。随着这些想法的出现，他对旺达以及迈克尔认为的她的不忠
and betrayal, and the guy that she was seeing as well, he began to just draw this incredible rage and hatred toward them. And he made a new decision and a new plan, which was instead of killing himself that day, he would kill them first and then kill himself. When he goes back into the back of the restaurant with his gun to carry out his plan, Wanda is standing with a male co-worker.
和背叛，以及她正在交往的那个男人，产生了难以置信的愤怒和仇恨。他做出了一个新的决定和一个新的计划，那就是与其那天自杀，不如先杀了他们，然后再自杀。当他带着枪回到餐厅后面执行他的计划时，旺达正和一个男同事站在一起。
And sure enough, almost matching what he saw in his mind's eye, they were both laughing or joking about something. And when Michael appeared, they continued to kind of laugh and smile. But Michael interpreted this as this complete derision and mockery of him. And that was enough for him to unleash his rage entirely.
果然，几乎和他脑海中想象的一样，他们都在笑着或开着什么玩笑。当迈克尔出现时，他们继续笑着、微笑着。但迈克尔将此解读为对他的彻底嘲弄和讥讽。这足以让他彻底释放他的愤怒。
He fired first at the man, and then he fired at Wanda. Michael learned later that the man that he shot, William, was not, in fact, at all a person who was having an affair with Wanda. He just happened to be a co-worker in the restaurant at the time. When the police came to arrest Michael in the restaurant, he gave a statement to them. What did he tell them, James? He tells them that at the moment that he shot and killed them, he felt relief, anger, and disbelief.
他先向那个男人开枪，然后向旺达开枪。迈克尔后来得知，他射杀的那个男人威廉，实际上根本不是与旺达有染的人。他当时只是餐厅里的一名同事。当警察来餐厅逮捕迈克尔时，他向他们发表了一份声明。他告诉了他们什么，詹姆斯？他告诉他们，在他开枪打死他们的那一刻，他感到解脱、愤怒和难以置信。
So James, you met Michael Stokes in 2019. What were the circumstances that got you in contact with him? Yeah, Michael actually reached out to me. He had read about in a news story some of my research on revenge and the power that it can have over us and the ability to cause people to commit acts of violence. And he wanted to ask if I could help him understand why he would have killed Wanda and William. It was about 26 years ago at the time. And I agreed to meet with him and begin to explore with him what was happening inside his mind at the time. How did he strike you when you talked to him? This is of course a quarter century after the terrible incident took place
那么詹姆斯，你在2019年见到了迈克尔·斯托克斯。是什么情况让你与他取得了联系？是的，迈克尔实际上主动联系了我。他读过一篇关于我的一些复仇研究以及复仇对我们可能产生的影响，以及导致人们实施暴力行为的能力的新闻报道。他想问我是否能帮他理解为什么他会杀了旺达和威廉。当时大约是26年前的事了。我同意去见他，并开始和他一起探索他当时脑子里在想什么。当你和他交谈时，他给你留下了什么印象？这当然是在那起可怕的事件发生四分之一个世纪之后
He must have been a quite a different person by that point, but how did he come across to you James? Yeah, I was you know as as you might be a little Little concerned and trepidatious going into the prison to meet him But Michael turned out to be an incredibly nice soft-spoken man. He, for the past 20 years in prison, had been volunteering as a hospice worker inside the prison helping inmates as they go through the process of dying. He had received certification as a nurse's aide helping the medical team. He had received some awards from the warden for helping an inmate who had been choking to death
到那时他一定已经是一个完全不同的人了，但詹姆斯，他给你留下了什么印象？是的，你知道，正如你可能的那样，进入监狱去见他时会有点担心和忐忑。但迈克尔结果是一个非常友善、说话轻声细语的人。在过去的20年里，他在监狱里一直担任临终关怀志愿者，帮助囚犯度过死亡的过程。他获得了护士助理的认证，协助医疗团队。他曾因帮助一名窒息濒死的囚犯而受到监狱长的嘉奖
by performing the Heimlich maneuver. And as a matter of fact, in 2024, he received, he and one other inmate were the first two inmates in the history of the Connecticut prison system to have earned bachelor's degrees while being incarcerated. So very different from the man who would have gunned down two people in cold blood. Heartache, rage, betrayal, loneliness. We've all experienced these emotions. While most
通过实施海姆立克急救法。事实上，在2024年，他和另一名囚犯成为康涅狄格州监狱系统历史上首批在服刑期间获得学士学位的囚犯。所以这与那个冷血枪杀两人的男人截然不同。心痛、愤怒、背叛、孤独。我们都经历过这些情绪。虽然大多数
of us would never act on these feelings in an extreme way, are the same mechanisms that compel Michael Stokes also lurking within our own minds? When we come back, the psychology of revenge. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. In 1993, Michael Stokes walked into a fast food restaurant and shot two people dead. One of them, a woman who had rejected his advances. The other, a man Michael mistakenly thought was her lover. At Yale University, James Kimmel studies the science of revenge.
我们绝不会以极端的方式对这些感受采取行动，但促使迈克尔·斯托克斯采取行动的机制是否也潜伏在我们自己的脑海中？回来后，我们将探讨复仇的心理学。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。1993年，迈克尔·斯托克斯走进一家快餐店，枪杀了两人。其中一人是拒绝了他追求的女性。另一人是迈克尔误以为是她情人的男人。在耶鲁大学，詹姆斯·金梅尔研究复仇的科学。
James, you say that after meeting Michael Stokes, you reflected on how his life could have been your life. Take me back to your childhood. You grew up on a small farm in Pennsylvania, but you did not come from a farming family. And I understand this posed something of a problem in your community? Yes, yes it did. So I moved to this farm. My folks moved me to the farm when I was 12 years old. And I grew up on that farm. And it was a good place to grow up. We had a herd of cattle, black Angus cattle. We had some pigs, chickens. We did hunting. It was a great place to be a boy, and I had a good time there. But one of the things I wanted out of that experience was to really befriend the farm kids around me. It was a bit of an isolated experience growing up on a
詹姆斯，你说在见到迈克尔·斯托克斯后，你反思了他的生活如何可能成为你的生活。带我回到你的童年。你在宾夕法尼亚州的一个小农场长大，但你并非来自农场家庭。我了解到这在你的社区造成了一些问题？是的，确实如此。我搬到了这个农场。我父母在我12岁时把我搬到了农场。我在那个农场长大。那是一个成长的好地方。我们有一群牛，安格斯黑牛。我们有一些猪、鸡。我们去打猎。作为一个男孩，那是一个很棒的地方，我在那里度过了一段美好的时光。但我从那次经历中想要得到的一件事是，真正与我周围的农场孩子交朋友。在农场长大是一种有点孤立的经历，因为
farm because the distances are great between homes. But I began to meet them in school and really tried to befriend them. I began to dress like them, wearing farmers' kinds of boots and jeans and flannel shirts and tractor hats and all that kind of stuff and listening to country music. Unfortunately, they were not going to have me, an outsider, come into this community in that way. And that was probably exacerbated by the fact that we didn't make, my family didn't make or living from the farm. My dad was actually an insurance agent. So he was going into the local town, maybe 10 AM dressed in a suit and their dads were up at 4 AM and out in the milking parlor, knee deep in manure, milking the cows. So they kept me out of their community and that was painful enough, but
家庭之间的距离很远。但我开始在学校见到他们，并真的试图与他们交朋友。我开始像他们一样穿衣，穿着农夫那种靴子、牛仔裤、法兰绒衬衫、拖拉机帽之类的东西，听乡村音乐。不幸的是，他们并不打算让我这个局外人以那种方式进入这个社区。这可能因为我们不是靠农场谋生而加剧了这种情况。我父亲实际上是一名保险代理人。所以他可能在上午10点穿着西装进城，而他们的父亲在凌晨4点就起床，深陷粪便中挤牛奶。所以他们把我挡在他们的社区之外，这已经足够痛苦了，但
eventually they took to bullying me as I got older in high school. So one night when you were 17 years old, you were home with your parents and brother. You were sleeping in bed, but you awoke to a loud noise. What was this noise, James? Yeah, that noise was a gunshot. It, you know, knocked us out of bed. We went to the windows to see what was going on. And, you know, when I looked out the window, I saw a pickup truck owned by one of the guys who had been harassing me and bullying me in school.
随着我在高中长大，他们最终开始欺负我。所以有一天晚上，当你17岁时，你和父母及兄弟在家。你正在床上睡觉，但被一声巨响惊醒。这是什么声音，詹姆斯？是的，那声音是枪声。它把我们从床上震了下来。我们走到窗前看看发生了什么。当我看向窗外时，我看到一辆皮卡车，属于一个在学校骚扰和欺负我的家伙。
I saw the truck taking off into the night and we checked around the house to see if there was any damage and we didn't find any and went back to bed. What happened the next morning? So one of my jobs before going to school in the morning was to take care of the animals and feed and water them. And I went out to the barn to feed and water the cows and the pigs. And there was also a dog pen out there where we kept this beautiful beagle hunting dog named Paula.
我看到那辆卡车消失在夜色中，我们检查了房子周围看看是否有损坏，但没有发现，于是又回去睡觉了。第二天早上发生了什么？所以我在早上上学前的工作之一是照顾动物，给它们喂食和喂水。我走到谷仓去给牛和猪喂食和喂水。那里还有一个狗圈，我们养了一只漂亮的猎兔犬，名叫宝拉（Paula）。
And when I went to her pen, I found her lying dead in the pen in a pool of blood with a bullet hole through her head. How did you feel in that moment, James? Yeah, it was terrible. Seeing your dog killed is a terrible thing to witness, knowing who killed her and why, these are guys who were my enemies, but why would they go to such a length, a horrific length to kill an innocent dog, just to make a point with me or retaliate against me or whatever was in their heads, was just absolutely shocking. A couple of weeks later, you were at home alone and you heard a vehicle approach the house. Describe for me what happened. Yeah, there was a vehicle that came up and as I was getting up to look out the window and see what was happening, I saw that same pickup truck,
当我走到她的围栏时，我发现她躺在围栏里，死在血泊中，头上有一个弹孔。那一刻你感觉如何，詹姆斯？是的，太可怕了。看到你的狗被杀是一件可怕的事情，知道是谁杀了她以及为什么，这些人是我的敌人，但他们为什么要走得那么远，以如此可怕的方式杀害一只无辜的狗，仅仅是为了向我示威，或者对我进行报复，或者无论他们脑子里在想什么，这都绝对令人震惊。几周后，你独自在家，听到一辆车靠近房子。描述一下发生了什么。是的，有一辆车开了过来，当我起身看向窗外想看看发生了什么时，我看到了那辆同样的皮卡车，
but then there was a flash and an explosion. They had blown up our mailbox and shot it into the neighboring cornfield. That was kind of it for me. I had been putting up with their abuse for, I don't know, three or four years now, and I had never retaliated. I tried to resist what they were doing but never in any type of a
但随后是一道闪光和一声爆炸。他们炸毁了我们的邮箱，并把它射进了邻近的玉米地。对我来说，这就算完了。我已经忍受了他们的虐待，不知道，三四年了，我从来没有报复过。我试图抵制他们的所作所为，但从来没有以任何类型的
violent way. But now with everything that had happened I decided that I couldn't deal with this any longer and I'd have to go to a much more extreme measure. I'd been on that farm since I was a young kid, had been shooting guns and hunting since I was about eight years old and we had plenty of guns in the house. My dad had a loaded handgun in his nightstand and I was all alone so I ran up I grabbed it out of the nightstand, jumped in my mother's car that night and I drove off after them. What were you trying to do? What was the plan? Well, at that point, the plan was to confront them. And I don't think that as I was putting
暴力方式。但现在发生了这一切，我决定我不能再忍受了，我必须采取更极端的措施。我从很小的时候就在那个农场，从大约八岁起就开始射击和打猎，我们家里有很多枪。我父亲的床头柜里有一把装满子弹的手枪，我一个人在家，所以我跑上去，从床头柜里抓起它，那天晚上跳进我母亲的车里，开车追了出去。你当时想做什么？计划是什么？嗯，在那一点上，计划是去对质他们。我不认为当我在制定
that plan together, I had a clear vision of what I was going to do at the stage of driving. But the plan started to formulate more closely when I was actually able to catch up to them and I cornered them against a barn on one of their farms. There were three or four of them in the pickup truck. Their truck was facing away from me, so I saw its foreheads in the window with my bright beams on the back of their truck. They climbed out and started squinting through my headlights to see who had chased them
那个计划时，在开车阶段，我对我要做什么有清晰的愿景。但当我真正追上他们并将他们逼到他们农场的一个谷仓边时，计划开始变得更加清晰。皮卡车里有三四个人。他们的卡车背对着我，所以我用远光灯照在他们卡车的后部，看到了窗户里的前额。他们爬出来，开始眯着眼睛透过我的车灯看是谁追赶他们
down this long farm road. It had taken some time for me to catch up to them, and they probably didn't have clear visibility, so I don't think that they knew exactly who had driven there or who was behind the wheel of that car that they were looking at. But it was clear that they were unarmed and they did not know that I had a gun. You know, I started to get out with the idea that this would be my opportunity to get revenge. And as I was getting out of the car, I had this insight. I could almost see into my future, and I realized that
沿着这条长长的农场路。我花了一些时间才追上他们，他们可能视线不清，所以我认为他们不知道到底是谁开车到那里，或者他们正在看的车后面坐着谁。但很明显他们没有武装，也不知道我有枪。你知道，我开始下车，心想这将是我复仇的机会。当我下车时，我有了这个洞察。我几乎能看到我的未来，我意识到
if I did what I wanted to do, if I had gunned them down, I would be killing myself as well. If not physically, then my identity, the James Kimmel Jr. that I knew before that moment, would no longer be that guy ever again. I'd always have to know myself as a murderer. That was not an identity that I was willing to accept for myself. I'd been raised better than that and I could see quickly that it really wouldn't put me
如果我做了我想做的事，如果我枪杀了他们，我也就等于自杀了。如果不是身体上的，那么我的身份，我在那一刻之前所认识的詹姆斯·金梅尔，将永远不再是那个人了。我将永远不得不以杀人犯的身份认识自己。那不是我愿意接受的身份。我受到的教育比那更好，我很快就能看出，这真的不会让我
in a better position. It would be far worse than I was already sitting in. And that realization was just enough to cause me to put the gun back down, pull my leg back in the car, shut the door and drive back home. So you and Michael Stokes in some ways shared the same impulse for revenge.
处于更好的境地。这会比我当时所处的境地糟糕得多。那个认识足以让我放下枪，把腿缩回车里，关上车门，开车回家。所以你和迈克尔·斯托克斯在某种程度上有着同样的复仇冲动。
You obviously handled those impulses very, very differently. But I understand that later on in life, you eventually became a lawyer and you found that the law was a way in some ways to enact your capacity for vengeance and revenge? Yeah, that's right. You know, lawyers are given in our society, you know, this very powerful license to get revenge. We're the only profession that's authorized and allowed to prescribe and manufacture and distribute justice in the form of revenge. That's what we do. And we get paid a lot of money for doing that. And I love the idea of becoming a lawyer in part because what it came down to for
你显然以非常、非常不同的方式处理了这些冲动。但我了解到，在以后的生活中，你最终成为了一名律师，你发现法律在某种程度上是你行使复仇能力的一种方式？是的，没错。你知道，律师在我们的社会中被赋予了这种非常强大的复仇许可。我们是唯一被授权和允许以复仇的形式开具、制造和分发正义的职业。这就是我们所做的。我们为此获得了丰厚的报酬。我喜欢成为律师的想法，部分原因在于它归结为
me that night with the farm kids is that I just wasn't willing to pay the high price that I'd have to pay to get revenge with a gun illegally. But I still wanted revenge and I wanted it badly against them and kind of against the world at this point as a young man. It's that kind of that male rage that everything's a raid against you. And I think the rage that Michael Stokes felt as well, that everything is a raid against me and I'm going to have to do something about it and I'm going to retaliate. I'm not going to take it anymore. So you found ways in the courtroom to increase the costs, the pressure, the pain that you were bringing to bear on the other side. And of course, there was a lawyer on the other side who was trying to do the same thing to you. And of course,
那天晚上我和农场孩子之间的事情是，我只是不愿意支付我非法用枪复仇所必须支付的高昂代价。但我仍然想要复仇，作为一个年轻人，我非常渴望对他们，甚至在某种程度上对世界进行复仇。这是一种男性的愤怒，觉得一切都在针对你。我认为迈克尔·斯托克斯感受到的愤怒也是如此，觉得一切都在针对我，我必须对此做点什么，我要报复。我不会再忍受了。所以你在法庭上找到了增加成本、压力、痛苦的方法，你把这些带给了对方。当然，对方也有一个律师在试图对你做同样的事情。当然，
what you then have are these cycles of retaliation. Yeah, that's exactly what litigation is. And you also have in that mix, clients on both sides who are desperately hungering for revenge, and they want their lawyers to increase the pain on the other side. That's the whole deal, right? I mean, it's revenge-seeking all the way around and we're all trying to hurt each other to the maximum legal extent possible and the legal system gives us many, many means to do that. I'm wondering how all of this affected you as a person. How did it affect your personal life?
你所拥有的就是这些报复循环。是的，诉讼就是这样。而且在那个组合中，双方的客户都极度渴望复仇，他们希望他们的律师增加对方的痛苦。这就是全部交易，对吧？我的意思是，这完全是寻求复仇，我们都在试图在法律允许的最大范围内伤害彼此，而法律体系给了我们许多许多手段来做到这一点。我想知道这一切是如何影响你个人的。它如何影响你的个人生活？
The fact that you were in some ways waging war in the courtroom is the picture that I'm getting. How did that affect you when you got home in the evenings? Very badly, unfortunately. What I was doing during the day carried over into my private life in all phases. I had home with my wife and my kids, with family and friends, with people I didn't know, neighbors, whoever got on the wrong side of me was going to be subjected to some form of threats, often legal threats,
我得到的画面是，你在法庭上以某种方式发动战争。当你晚上回家时，这对你有什么影响？非常糟糕，不幸的是。我白天所做的事情在各个阶段都延续到了我的私人生活中。我和妻子、孩子在一起，和家人、朋友在一起，和我不认识的人、邻居在一起，任何惹恼我的人都会受到某种形式的威胁，通常是法律威胁，
because that's the skill that I learned is how to get revenge through the court system. And it worked directly against my values. I'm a spiritual person. I was raised in a spiritual family. And I believe that Jesus's teachings of forgiveness must have meant something important or we wouldn't be considering them all these many years later. So in 2004 you read an article in the New York Times about a study that looked at why revenge feels good. What was this article about? Yeah, so that's probably the first, it's the first that I'm aware of at least, neuroscience study
因为我学到的技能就是如何通过法院系统进行复仇。这直接违背了我的价值观。我是一个有灵性的人。我在一个有灵性的家庭中长大。我相信耶稣关于宽恕的教导一定意味着什么重要的东西，否则我们不会在这么多年后还在考虑它们。所以在2004年，你读了《纽约时报》上的一篇文章，关于一项研究，探讨了为什么复仇感觉良好。这篇文章是关于什么的？是的，所以这可能是第一个，至少是我所知道的第一个神经科学研究
trying to understand what's happening inside the human brain when we have a grievance and this spools up a desire for revenge. The researchers there at the University of Zurich, they were engaged in trying to identify why humans engage in what they refer to as altruistic punishment. And that means punishing other people, other humans, for wrongs that they've committed even when it comes at a cost to the punisher, but for no benefit to the punisher, no discernible benefit. And those researchers theorize, they hypothesize that there must be some form of benefit. And if there's not going to be a material benefit to us when we punish someone, there must be some form of emotional or neural
试图理解当我们有怨恨时，人类大脑内部发生了什么，这会激发复仇的欲望。苏黎世大学的研究人员试图确定为什么人类会从事他们所说的利他惩罚。这意味着惩罚其他人，其他人类，因为他们犯下的错误，即使这需要惩罚者付出代价，但对惩罚者没有任何好处，没有可察觉的好处。那些研究人员推测，假设一定有某种形式的好处。如果我们惩罚某人时不会得到物质上的好处，那么一定有某种形式的情感或神经
benefit that we're getting from this. And they hypothesized that if that's true, that would manifest in the neural circuitry of pleasure and reward. So did they actually find a relationship? Did they do a brain scanning element of the study where they found that reward circuits of the brain were active? Yeah, that's exactly right. So they used PET scans in that study and they found that this one area of the brain that they wanted to focus on, the dorsal striatum, which is part of the pleasure and reward circuitry of the brain, that became active during the study among study participants as they were contemplating whether to punish fictional opponents in economic games that they were playing. So if the opponent in the economic game, while they were under the brain scanner, had cheated or betrayed them and given them, therefore, some form of a grievance or reason to be angry and to feel wronged. And then the opportunity in the game to punish, which they were given, by extracting money from the opponent. Then this area of the brain activated and it even activated when the cost of punishing the opponent would result in the complete bankruptcy and loss to the study participant during the game.
我们从中获得的好处。他们假设如果这是真的，那就会在快乐和奖励的神经回路中表现出来。那么他们真的发现了这种关系吗？他们是否进行了大脑扫描研究，发现大脑的奖励回路是活跃的？是的，完全正确。他们在研究中使用了PET扫描，他们发现他们想要关注的大脑的这个区域，背侧纹状体，它是大脑快乐和奖励回路的一部分，在研究参与者思考是否在他们玩的经济游戏中惩罚虚构对手时，该区域在研究中变得活跃。所以如果经济游戏中的对手，在他们接受大脑扫描时，欺骗或背叛了他们，从而给了他们某种形式的怨恨或愤怒和感到被冤枉的理由。然后游戏中有惩罚的机会，他们被给予了，通过从对手那里提取金钱。那么大脑的这个区域就会激活，甚至当惩罚对手的代价会导致研究参与者在游戏过程中彻底破产和损失时，它也会激活。
So they would lose the game but get to seek revenge anyway and a good number of study participants went through with the punishment even though they understood it would result in them instantly losing the game. In other words, I'm willing to bring the roof down over your head, even if it means bringing the roof down over mine. That's correct. So, if revenge is so closely tied up with pleasure and with potentially ignoring the costs that come with that pleasure, it starts to look like another domain where people ignore costs in the pursuit of pleasure. That's correct. And that's the insight that I had. Grievances activate
所以他们会输掉游戏，但无论如何都要寻求复仇，相当多的研究参与者即使在明白这会导致他们瞬间输掉游戏的情况下，也坚持进行了惩罚。换句话说，我愿意把屋顶掀翻在你的头上，即使这意味着把屋顶也掀翻在我的头上。没错。所以，如果复仇与快乐以及潜在地忽视随之而来的代价如此紧密地联系在一起，它看起来就像另一个人们在追求快乐时忽视代价的领域。没错。这就是我的洞察。怨恨会激活
revenge cravings and those revenge cravings very much look like drug addiction. The desire for revenge is very similar to the compulsion that substance users have to continue to engage in the use of addictive substances or other behavioral addictions such as gambling. I understand that you reached out to some neuroscientists who studied addiction to ask if they would be interested in working with you to develop this hypothesis? Yes. Yeah. The first place I went, so I'm still a lawyer at this point, although a lawyer without much of a home. But it was clear to me in my personal experience as a lawyer and by watching other lawyers and other litigants and then looking at the wider world around. And I'm talking about acts of
复仇渴望，而那些复仇渴望看起来非常像药物成瘾。复仇的欲望与物质使用者继续使用成瘾物质或其他行为成瘾（如赌博）的强迫感非常相似。我了解到你联系了一些研究成瘾的神经科学家，询问他们是否有兴趣与你合作发展这个假设？是的。是的。我当时去的第一地方，我当时仍然是一名律师，尽管是一个没有多少家的律师。但在我作为律师的个人经历中，通过观察其他律师和其他诉讼当事人，然后观察更广阔的世界，这对我来说很清楚。我指的是新闻中报道的暴力行为
violence that are reported in the news and all sorts of forms of revenge seeking that it's often compulsive. It seems as though people are unable to control their desire to do this, to act in this way, to engage in this behavior, it seems as though we're doing it even though we know there will be negative consequences that follow. And the more we get, the more we need, even though it's wrecking our lives and that it's filled with negative consequences. And so those things started to tick all of the boxes of addiction for me. And I began to consult with addiction scientists. And then one was Anna Rose Childress at the University of Pennsylvania and Paul Eislinger at Penn State. And I proposed this idea to them. And Anna Rose is a world-leading
以及各种形式的寻求复仇，这通常是强迫性的。看起来人们似乎无法控制自己做这件事的欲望，以这种方式行事，参与这种行为，看起来我们即使知道会有随之而来的负面后果，也在这样做。我们得到的越多，我们需要的就越多，尽管它正在摧毁我们的生活，并且充满了负面后果。所以这些事情对我来说开始勾选了成瘾的所有框框。我开始咨询成瘾科学家。其中一位是宾夕法尼亚大学的安娜·罗斯·查尔德里斯（Anna Rose Childress）和宾夕法尼亚州立大学的保罗·艾斯林格（Paul Eislinger）。我向他们提出了这个想法。安娜·罗斯是一位世界领先的
addiction researcher. And to my surprise, she not only listened, but she was very encouraged by the idea and captivated by it and thought that we ought to begin to apply for some grants and begin to research it and see whether we can prove that it's true. Ramesh Parakh, Ph.D. You eventually joined the psychiatry department at Yale, and you and others have explored the parallels between the desire for revenge and drug addiction. What happens in the brains of people seeking revenge, James? Yeah. So neuroscientists began to see what I was seeing, which is when you have a grievance, this triggers the reward and pleasure circuitry inside your
成瘾研究员。令我惊讶的是，她不仅听了，而且对这个想法非常受鼓舞，并被它吸引，认为我们应该开始申请一些资助，并开始研究它，看看我们是否能证明它是真的。拉梅什·帕拉赫（Ramesh Parakh）博士。你最终加入了耶鲁大学精神病学系，你和其他人探索了复仇欲望与药物成瘾之间的相似之处。詹姆斯，寻求复仇的人的大脑中发生了什么？是的。所以神经科学家开始看到我所看到的，那就是当你有了怨恨时，这会触发你大脑内部的奖励和快乐回路
brain just in the same way that seeing a place where you've taken drugs in the past if you're a drug user or seeing a casino if you're a gambling addict, seeing those things will cue in the brain cravings for, in our case, revenge, right? So the grievance triggers this craving for revenge. And if the prefrontal cortex of the brain, which is there to stop you from making bad decisions and give you strength in weighing costs and benefits. If that's inhibited, you might go through with a revenge-seeking act compulsively, which is to say beyond your control or inability to resist it. Can you tell me about the research of David Chester who looked at the relationship between the pain of rejection and the
就像如果你是一个吸毒者，看到你过去吸毒的地方，或者如果你是一个赌博成瘾者，看到赌场，看到这些东西会触发大脑中对复仇的渴望，在我们的例子中，对吧？所以怨恨触发了这种对复仇的渴望。如果大脑的前额叶皮层，它的存在是为了阻止你做出错误的决定，并在权衡成本和收益时给你力量。如果它受到抑制，你可能会强迫性地进行寻求复仇的行为，也就是说，超出了你的控制或无法抗拒它。你能告诉我大卫·切斯特（David Chester）的研究吗，他研究了拒绝的痛苦与
pleasure of revenge? Yeah, what he has found in his studies is he's gone beyond just economic games and set up some studies in which study participants, typically undergraduates at his university, are put in brain scanners and are given the opportunity to play some games in which they are subjected to noise blasts, for instance, if they lose the game. And these noise blasters, that's somewhat painful, mildly painful, but incredibly unfair because they've done nothing other than lose a game. So the design here is to create an instantly powerful grievance. Having stimulated them in this way, he then scanned their brains while giving them the opportunity to retaliate. And what he has found, Dr. Chester, is that in those instances, the nucleus accumbens area of the brain,
复仇的快乐之间的关系？是的，他在研究中发现的是，他已经超越了仅仅是经济游戏，并设置了一些研究，其中研究参与者，通常是他大学的本科生，被放入大脑扫描仪中，并有机会玩一些游戏，如果他们输了游戏，他们会受到噪音冲击，例如。这些噪音冲击，这有点痛苦，轻微的痛苦，但极其不公平，因为他们除了输掉游戏外什么也没做。所以这里的目的是创造一种瞬间强烈的怨恨。在以这种方式刺激他们之后，他在给他们报复机会的同时扫描了他们的大脑。切斯特博士发现，在这些情况下，大脑的伏隔核区域，
which is the most widely associated area of the brain with craving and compulsion. That area of the brain is becoming extremely active while study participants are considering retaliation. And at the same time, there's a loss of connectivity or silence with the prefrontal cortex, which is the executive function control area of the brain that's supposed to be stopping you from doing terrible things against your own interest, like seeking revenge. I understand that some of this work has also found that as people experience this spike in feelings of aggression or revenge, in some ways it ameliorates
这是大脑中最广泛地与渴望和强迫联系在一起的区域。当研究参与者考虑报复时，大脑的那个区域变得极其活跃。与此同时，与前额叶皮层的连接性丧失或沉默，这是大脑的执行功能控制区域，本应阻止你做出违背自身利益的可怕事情，比如寻求复仇。我了解到，这项工作中的一些研究还发现，当人们经历这种攻击性或复仇感的激增时，在某种程度上它缓解了
the negative mood that they're experiencing. It helps to repair the sense of grievance that they're experiencing. Yeah, and I'm glad you brought that up. So right, what is the end game here? It activates the pleasure and reward circuitry to what extent? We now know revenge seeking is incredibly pleasurable. Revenge acts like a drug inside our brains. But like a drug, the pleasure is short-lived. And this appears to be the same experience for revenge seekers. Fantasizing about revenge is incredibly pleasurable. Engaging in it is
他们正在经历的负面情绪。它有助于修复他们正在经历的怨恨感。是的，我很高兴你提到了这一点。所以没错，这里的终局是什么？它在多大程度上激活了快乐和奖励回路？我们现在知道寻求复仇是非常令人愉快的。复仇在我们的大脑中就像一种药物。但像药物一样，快乐是短暂的。对于复仇者来说，这似乎也是同样的经历。幻想复仇是非常令人愉快的。参与其中是
incredibly pleasurable. But these pleasures are short-lived and leave us with both feeling worse, but also in harm's way because our act of pleasurable revenge seeking becomes the other person's act of grievance and provocation or experience, I should say act of grievance and provocation, or experience, I should say, of grievance and provocation, igniting their revenge-seeking desire. And so we, throughout human history, have experienced these revenge cycles over and over again. Most of us cloak revenge in the language of morality. An eye for an eye, a tooth for a tooth.
非常令人愉快的。但这些快乐是短暂的，让我们感觉更糟，但也让我们处于危险之中，因为我们寻求快乐复仇的行为变成了对方的怨恨和挑衅行为，或者说经历，我应该说是怨恨和挑衅的经历，点燃了他们寻求复仇的欲望。因此，在整个人类历史上，我们一次又一次地经历了这些复仇循环。我们大多数人将复仇披上了道德的外衣。以眼还眼，以牙还牙。
But what if revenge has little to do with justice? What if it's driven by ancient algorithms in the brain? When we come back, can we treat revenge addiction the way we treat other addictions? Should we? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Revenge feels instinctive. When we seek vengeance, it feels like we are balancing the scales, restoring order, making things right. The urge to strike back doesn't just seem justified. It feels necessary. James Kimmel Jr. says that vengeance promises our satisfaction and relief from pain. But
但如果复仇与正义几乎没有关系呢？如果它是被大脑中的古老算法驱动的呢？回来后，我们能像对待其他成瘾一样对待复仇成瘾吗？我们应该这样做吗？你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。复仇感觉是本能的。当我们寻求复仇时，感觉就像我们在平衡天平，恢复秩序，拨乱反正。反击的冲动不仅看起来是正当的。它感觉是必要的。詹姆斯·金梅尔说，复仇承诺我们的满足和痛苦的缓解。但是
like other kinds of addiction, we can pay a huge price for brief moments of satisfaction. James, you came up with a study to test an anti-revenge intervention that you call the non-justice system, where a victim enacts all the different roles of a courtroom trial. You gave volunteers a scenario. They go on vacation and they leave their dog with a neighbor Billy. When they return from their trip, they find their dog is missing. Billy says he ran away. But the volunteers in the study soon discover this isn't true. They find out that Billy is part of a dog fighting ring and that he used their pet as a bait dog to train another animal to kill. How
就像其他类型的成瘾一样，我们可能会为短暂的满足感付出巨大的代价。詹姆斯，你设计了一项研究来测试一种反复仇干预措施，你称之为“非司法系统”，即受害者在模拟法庭审判中扮演所有不同的角色。你给志愿者提供了一个场景：他们去度假，把狗留给邻居比利照顾。旅行回来后，他们发现狗不见了。比利说狗跑了。但研究中的志愿者很快发现这不是真的。他们发现比利是一个斗狗团伙的成员，他把他们的宠物当作诱饵犬来训练另一只动物去杀戮。那么
do people respond to this scenario, James? They're just absolutely furious and wanting revenge at a very high level. And so we were able to measure that during the study. And revenge desires before reading this dog killing scenario and after show that revenge desires just skyrocket and go right through the roof, which is where we need them to be in order to try the intervention against those revenge desires and see whether it is effective at reducing them. So when you have people now undertake this non-justice system where they're essentially playing all the roles in the courtroom, I'm wondering even what this sounds like just
人们对这个场景有何反应，詹姆斯？他们感到非常愤怒，并有着极高程度的复仇欲望。因此，我们在研究过程中能够测量到这一点。在阅读这个杀狗场景之前和之后，复仇欲望的对比显示，复仇欲望会直线飙升，达到顶峰，而这正是我们需要达到的状态，以便针对这些复仇欲望进行干预，看看它在减少这些欲望方面是否有效。所以，当人们现在进行这个“非司法系统”时，他们本质上是在扮演法庭上的所有角色，我甚至想知道这听起来是什么样的，就在
in this scenario. I mean, what would it sound like to play all the different roles of the people engaged in this particular scenario? So in the non-justice system, if you're the victim, you get to play the victim and prosecutor, and you get to play the defendant. You play the judge and jury, you play the warden, and you play ultimately the judge of your own life in the final step. So you're playing all of those roles. In playing the victim and prosecutor role, it gives the victim an opportunity at that point to be heard. And that's what courtrooms around
这个场景中。我的意思是，扮演这个特定场景中所有不同的人的角色，听起来会是什么样？在“非司法系统”中，如果你是受害者，你可以扮演受害者和检察官，你也可以扮演被告。你扮演法官和陪审团，扮演狱卒，最后在最后一步扮演你自己人生的审判者。所以你扮演了所有这些角色。在扮演受害者和检察官的角色时，它给了受害者一个在那一刻被倾听的机会。而这正是世界各地的
the world serve. One of their purposes is to be heard, to let other people know that you've been harmed, and hopefully to elicit some form of sympathy or understanding that yes, this in fact happened and we all feel maybe bad about it. That's step one. In step two, as the defendant, we've seen study participants deeply spending a deep amount of time thinking about what the person who wronged them would say, what excuses they would bring, whether they would admit or deny it,
法庭所服务的功能。它们的目的之一就是让人被倾听，让其他人知道你受到了伤害，并希望引起某种形式的同情或理解，即“是的，这确实发生了，我们都为此感到难过”。这是第一步。在第二步中，作为被告，我们看到研究参与者花费大量时间深入思考伤害他们的人会说什么，他们会找什么借口，他们是会承认还是否认，
whether they would concoct a story, whether they would be callous and hateful and happy that they've done what they've done. So testifying as Billy, some study participants not necessarily having sympathy for Billy but empathy with the idea that in some cultures and communities dogfighting is part of that culture. It's not considered to be a horrific event and that Billy was probably caught up in that and was just doing what he had been taught. Most participants found it difficult to hold this viewpoint. They saw Billy instead as a perpetrator, someone willing to lie and make excuses for his violent
他们是否会编造故事，他们是否会冷酷无情、幸灾乐祸。因此，作为比利作证时，一些研究参与者不一定是对比利有同情心，而是对这样一种观点有共鸣：在某些文化和社区中，斗狗是该文化的一部分。它不被认为是一件可怕的事情，比利可能只是卷入其中，只是在做他被教导要做的事情。大多数参与者发现很难持有这种观点。他们反而将比利视为加害者，一个愿意撒谎并为自己的暴力行为找借口的人。
actions. After the volunteers played the role of defendant and the role of the prosecutor, they were also asked to play the roles of judge and jury in the case. Then the study participant moves out of the role as defendant and now I get to look at all of the facts and circumstances and come up with the best arguments for and against guilt or innocence and then to hand down a verdict. In most instances, in the Billy scenario, the verdict is guilt, that Billy is guilty for what he's done. And then the participants given an opportunity to hand down a sentence. That sentence in the non-justice system can be
在志愿者扮演了被告和检察官的角色后，他们还被要求在案件中扮演法官和陪审团的角色。然后，研究参与者从被告的角色中走出来，现在我可以审视所有的事实和情况，提出关于有罪或无罪的最佳论点，然后做出判决。在大多数情况下，在比利这个场景中，判决是有罪，即比利对他所做的事情负有罪责。然后，参与者有机会做出量刑。在“非司法系统”中，这个判决可以是
anything you want, right? So it's not just what would be allowed in a court of law, for instance, a term of incarceration or a fine or probation or parole. When we give victims the opportunity to pick any punishment they want, they will come up with some pretty hard and sadistic things. They will want Billy put in a cage with a pack of dogs and literally torn to shreds. Wow. So I'm trying to figure out here how this is a substitute for revenge here, James. It feels it can be pretty bloodthirsty. That's correct until the last step. So the goal here, if you think of this as methadone for a revenge addict, this is giving the victim an opportunity to be heard, to experience revenge in a safe way inside their brain, not
任何你想要的，对吧？所以它不仅仅是法律允许的，例如监禁、罚款、缓刑或假释。当我们给受害者机会去选择他们想要的任何惩罚时，他们会想出一些非常严厉和残忍的事情。他们会希望把比利关进一个装满狗的笼子里，让他被活活撕碎。哇。所以我在这里试图弄清楚这怎么能成为复仇的替代品，詹姆斯。这感觉可能相当嗜血。没错，直到最后一步。所以这里的目标是，如果你把它想象成复仇成瘾者的美沙酮，这就是给受害者一个被倾听的机会，在他们的大脑中以一种安全的方式体验复仇，而不是
out in the real world, and to release that desire and that craving. But also as the warden, you have to experience being the person who's inflicting the punishment. And so if you wanted Billy to be put in a cage and torn to shreds, you can't just say that's the sentence and walk away and hope it happens. You have to be the one who creates that circumstance and is there watching it from beginning until end and considering whether you really feel better watching Billy being torn to shreds or whether a part of you is starting to emerge that's in even deeper pain than you imagined because now you've been the instrument of this other person's torture and death. At the last step though, everything has changed. It's an all new courtroom. It's a courtroom that's a higher place where the judge in this courtroom
在现实世界中，并释放那种欲望和渴望。但同时作为狱卒，你必须体验成为施加惩罚的人。所以如果你想让比利被关进笼子里撕碎，你不能只是说那是判决然后走开，希望它发生。你必须是那个创造那种情况的人，并从头到尾看着它，考虑你看着比利被撕碎是否真的感觉更好，或者你内心深处是否开始涌现出比你想象中更深层的痛苦，因为现在你已经成为了折磨和杀害这个人的工具。然而在最后一步，一切都变了。这是一个全新的法庭。这是一个更高的法庭，法官在这个法庭上
is high above you and begins asking you a few questions. Namely, first, is the grievance that you've experienced, is that happening here today and can it be experienced with your senses or is it only in the past? And we begin at that point to start to realize, oh, the grievance that I'm carrying maybe years after the fact is deep in the past. It only exists as a thought formation inside my brain. And then you're asked at that point, well, if that's so, what might it be like to forgive the person who wronged you?
高高在上，开始问你几个问题。即，首先，你所经历的委屈，今天在这里发生了吗？它是可以用你的感官体验到的，还是只存在于过去？我们在那一刻开始意识到，哦，我在事后多年仍背负的委屈，深埋在过去。它只作为我大脑中的一种思维模式存在。然后你在那一刻被问到，好吧，如果真是这样，原谅那个伤害你的人会是什么感觉？
Now, almost no one wants to forgive, but if you just imagine it so you don't have to forgive, you imagine it, what we find is that most people who imagine forgiving something after going through this huge burden of prosecuting and punishing another person realizes that they feel this immediate sense of relief from forgiving. And what the neuroscience shows, actually, is that that's what happens. Forgiveness shuts down the pain center in your brain, it shuts down the revenge craving center in your brain, and
现在，几乎没有人想原谅，但如果你只是想象一下，这样你就不必真的原谅，你只是想象它，我们发现大多数在经历了起诉和惩罚他人的巨大负担后想象原谅的人，会意识到他们从原谅中感受到了一种即时的解脱感。而神经科学实际上表明，这就是所发生的情况。原谅会关闭你大脑中的疼痛中心，关闭你大脑中的复仇渴望中心，并且
it activates the executive function center in your brain. It does all of these things. It's possibly the most important self-healing mechanism we all have inside our heads, and yet we kind of don't know it's there much of the time. I'm wondering how effective this has been in the real world. Besides in laboratory settings, is there any evidence that this actually works in helping people deal with real-world grievances, James? Yeah, it does. Soon after I created this in 2005, I think around 2009, 10, we began to use it in some Pennsylvania prisons as part of a pilot
它会激活你大脑中的执行功能中心。它能做到所有这些事情。这可能是我们每个人头脑中最重要的自我修复机制，但我们大部分时间却不知道它的存在。我想知道这在现实世界中有多有效。除了在实验室环境中，有什么证据表明这真的能帮助人们处理现实世界的委屈吗，詹姆斯？是的，确实有效。我在2005年创建这个系统后不久，我想大约在2009、10年，我们开始在宾夕法尼亚州的一些监狱中使用它，作为试点项目的一部分，
project to help inmates there who were preparing to come back into society, but obviously had powerful revenge desires unresolved and usually exacerbated while being in prison. We weren't able to study the effectiveness of the intervention there, but the results of their staying out of prison for at least a year afterward were extremely promising. So that was good news. The intervention is used by a group of violence interrupters in the New Haven area to prevent the next round level of retaliatory street violence. So when they go to, for instance, a hospital where the family and friends of a victim of a gun shooting are located and everybody is just absolutely thirsting for revenge. They use the intervention, in particular that last step that
帮助那些准备重返社会的囚犯，但他们显然有强大的、未解决的复仇欲望，而且在监狱中通常会加剧。我们无法在那里研究干预措施的有效性，但他们之后至少一年没有再入狱的结果是非常令人鼓舞的。所以这是个好消息。纽黑文地区的一群暴力干预者使用这种干预措施来防止下一轮报复性的街头暴力。所以当他们去，例如，去一家医院，那里有枪击案受害者的家人和朋友，每个人都绝对渴望复仇时。他们使用这种干预措施，特别是我们刚才谈到的最后一步，
we were talking about, to help calm that down, reduce the pain, and reduce that desire for revenge. I mean, one thing that I'm taking away from what you're saying James is that when we think about grievances, especially grievances that we have carried around for many years or many decades sometimes, we often tell ourselves the reason I'm holding on to this grievance is because I have this very sharp sense of fairness and justice. And I'm carrying around this grievance because at some point in the future I hope to, you know, level the scales of justice and basically, you know, make sure that the good guys win and the bad guys lose. But as you're talking here, what I'm really hearing is that part of the
来帮助平息情绪，减轻痛苦，并减少那种复仇的欲望。我的意思是，我从你所说的话中得到的一点是，当我们思考委屈时，特别是我们背负了多年甚至几十年的委屈，我们经常告诉自己，我坚持这种委屈的原因是因为我有这种非常敏锐的公平和正义感。我背负着这种委屈，因为在未来的某个时候，我希望，你知道，平衡正义的天平，基本上，你知道，确保好人获胜，坏人失败。但正如你在这里所说的，我真正听到的是，我们背负这种委屈感的部分
reason we're carrying around this sense of grievance is that at some level it is giving us pleasure to carry around this revenge fantasy. So if you think about this from an addiction model, you know, I'm carrying around the grievance very much like the way I'm carrying around the picture of the bar or the casino in my head. You know, it's not really about justice. It's about, you know, trying to satiate this drive for pleasure.
原因在于，在某种程度上，背负这种复仇幻想给我们带来了快乐。所以如果你从成瘾模型的角度来思考这个问题，你知道，我背负着委屈，非常像我脑子里背负着酒吧或赌场的画面。你知道，这真的不是关于正义。这是关于，你知道，试图满足这种对快乐的驱动。
That's correct. The trouble with it though is that that pleasure is this cruel form of pleasure. That's correct. The trouble with it though is that that pleasure is this cruel form of pleasure. It's this always taunting, always nagging experience that people with a gambling use disorder or substance use disorder are experiencing, which is this nagging craving that I can satisfy in moments at a time followed by feeling worse and then the craving returning. And this is happening for us over and over again, revenge rumination, where we could ruminate on the same grievance for decades even and never allowing it to go. I mean, blood feuds throughout history are based on that idea of the scale is never balanced.
没错。但它的麻烦在于，那种快乐是一种残酷的快乐形式。没错。它的麻烦在于，那种快乐是一种残酷的快乐形式。这是一种总是嘲弄、总是唠叨的体验，患有赌博障碍或物质使用障碍的人正在经历这种体验，这是一种唠叨的渴望，我可以一次次地满足它，随后感觉更糟，然后渴望又回来了。这种情况在我们身上反复发生，复仇反刍，我们可以对同一个委屈反刍几十年，甚至从不让它过去。我的意思是，历史上的血海深仇都是基于那种天平永远无法平衡的想法。
Even when you get to the point of getting your revenge, there is no balance because you've just now created an all new grievance and an all new and balanced scale. So it's this cruel, torturous experience that humanity continues to put itself through that we really don't have to if we understand what's going on and that the way to feel better lasting as opposed to just as for a temporary high is to let go of that grievance. When we come back, what happens when revenge addiction goes global? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta.
即使当你达到复仇的那一刻，也没有平衡，因为你刚刚创造了一个全新的委屈和一个全新的、不平衡的天平。所以这是一种残酷的、折磨人的体验，人类继续让自己经历这种体验，如果我们了解发生了什么，并且知道感觉持久好转的方法，而不是仅仅为了暂时的快感，就是放下那种委屈，我们其实不必经历这些。回来后，当复仇成瘾走向全球时会发生什么？你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
James Kimmel Jr. is the author of The Science of Revenge, understanding the world's deadliest addiction and how to overcome it. He says revenge isn't just something that affects us as individuals. It affects groups, even countries. So James, you say that three of the most dangerous people in human history, Adolf Hitler, Joseph Stalin, and Chairman Mao, were revenge addicts. Let's look at each of them in turn. How was Hitler motivated by revenge?
詹姆斯·金梅尔（James Kimmel Jr.）是《复仇科学：理解世界上最致命的成瘾及其克服方法》一书的作者。他说，复仇不仅仅是影响我们个人的事情。它影响群体，甚至国家。所以詹姆斯，你说人类历史上三个最危险的人——阿道夫·希特勒、约瑟夫·斯大林和毛主席——都是复仇成瘾者。让我们依次看看他们每个人。希特勒是如何被复仇驱动的？
Yeah, so Hitler's motivation for revenge is found in speeches that he gave when he was just ascending in Germany. He focused all of his energy, not on a productive campaign that he wanted to lead for Germany and how he wanted to improve conditions. All of his discussion throughout essentially all of his speeches in his leadership of the country was based on his grievances and the grievances of the German people primarily against the Jews and other
是的，希特勒的复仇动机可以在他刚在德国崛起时发表的演讲中找到。他把所有的精力都集中在复仇上，而不是他想为德国领导的一场富有成效的运动，以及他想如何改善条件上。他在领导国家期间，几乎所有演讲中的讨论，本质上都是基于他的委屈，以及德国人民对犹太人和其他
politicians for first of all, and most importantly, the stab in the back myth, in which the accusation was laid that German politicians and Jews had caused Germany to accept the terms of the Treaty of Versailles ending World War I. And so historians have now really identified World War I and the way it was resolved as the source cause of World War II. And that's because at the resolution of World War I, the Treaty of Versailles, the German nation was put under extreme reparations and punishment for having begun World War I. And the politicians who signed the armistice leading to the Treaty of Versailles were considered by some Germans and Hitler to have betrayed Germany. Hitler wanted
政客的委屈，首先，也是最重要的，是“背后捅刀”的神话，指控德国政客和犹太人导致德国接受了结束第一次世界大战的《凡尔赛条约》的条款。因此，历史学家现在真正将第一次世界大战及其解决方式确定为第二次世界大战的根源。这是因为在第一次世界大战结束时，《凡尔赛条约》让德国国家因发动一战而承受了极端的赔偿和惩罚。而签署导致《凡尔赛条约》的停战协议的政客，被一些德国人和希特勒认为背叛了德国。希特勒想要
revenge for that and quickly over the course of 20 years built up in an amazing system for seeking nationwide revenge through the infliction of grievances upon the people, the repetition of these grievances, and the guarantees and promises that if he was put in power, he would retaliate against all of Germany's internal enemies first and then their external enemies and he delivered on that promise. So a few years before Hitler was rising to power in 1915, this was in fact two years before the Russian Revolution and long before he was the ruler of the Soviet Union, Joseph Stalin was serving an exile in Siberia and while he was there he was asked by one of his comrades, what was his greatest pleasure?
为那件事复仇，并在20年间迅速建立了一个惊人的系统，通过向人民施加委屈、重复这些委屈，以及保证和承诺如果他掌权，他将首先对德国所有的内部敌人进行报复，然后是外部敌人，他兑现了那个承诺。所以，在希特勒1915年掌权的前几年，这实际上是在俄国革命前两年，也是在他成为苏联统治者很久之前，约瑟夫·斯大林在西伯利亚流放，当他在那里时，他的一位同志问他，他最大的快乐是什么？
How did he respond to that, James? So in response to this question, Stalin says, my greatest pleasure is to choose one's victim, prepare one's plans minutely, slake an implacable vengeance, and then go to bed. There's nothing sweeter in the world. I mean in some ways this is a textbook example of what you've been talking about here, about the pleasures of vengeance and revenge. That's correct. It's an incredible quote. He is not even the leader of the Soviet Union at that point, but he's explaining even in his early years as a 36-year-old that vengeance is his greatest pleasure in life. And I recount in the book going back to his youth and his teen and young adult years that
他是如何回答的，詹姆斯？所以为了回答这个问题，斯大林说：“我最大的快乐是选择一个受害者，仔细准备计划，满足一种不可调和的复仇，然后上床睡觉。世界上没有什么比这更甜美的了。”我的意思是，在某些方面，这是你在这里谈论的关于复仇的快乐的一个教科书式的例子。没错。这是一个令人难以置信的引语。他当时甚至还不是苏联的领导人，但他甚至在他36岁早年时就解释说，复仇是他一生中最大的快乐。我在书中回顾了他年轻和青少年时期，
he was a revenge seeker extraordinaire in all sorts of ways, including committing a huge bank robbery that left many people dead. And in all instances, he was always not robbing the bank for the money, he was robbing it to retaliate for some vengeance that he believed had been perpetrated and balancing the scales. In the 1920s, Chairman Mao in China writes to his party bosses about the violence that he has managed to unleash. What does he say, James? Yeah. So as Mao was experimenting with communism and rising through the Communist Party, he was put in charge of an entire region of China. But he had the idea when he was doing that of encouraging peasants to begin to rise up against the landowners and landlords that had been oppressing them. And his
他是一个各方面的复仇追求者，包括犯下了一起导致多人死亡的巨大银行抢劫案。在所有情况下，他抢劫银行从来不是为了钱，他是为了报复他认为已经实施的某种复仇，并平衡天平。20世纪20年代，毛主席在中国写信给他的党内高层，谈论他设法释放的暴力。他说了什么，詹姆斯？是的。当毛泽东尝试共产主义并在共产党内崛起时，他被任命负责中国的一个地区。但他当时有一个想法，鼓励农民开始反抗一直压迫他们的地主和房东。他的
idea was to encourage them to retaliate against this oppression rather than having the Communist Party do the dirty work. They could encourage the peasants and encouraging villagers to engage in struggle sessions in which they effectively put the landlords and people that they thought were abusing them on trial and then marching them through the streets wearing pointy dunce caps while beating them, torturing them, and in some cases actually killing them. After having done all of this, he reports back to the leaders in the Communist Party that he really had created terror in the countryside and that for him it felt like a kind of ecstasy never experienced before. I'm wondering if you see the same patterns of revenge, intoxication in modern conflicts,
想法是鼓励他们报复这种压迫，而不是让共产党做脏活。他们可以鼓励农民和村民进行“斗争会”，在会上他们有效地审判了地主和他们认为虐待他们的人，然后让他们戴着尖尖的傻瓜帽游街，同时殴打他们、折磨他们，在某些情况下实际上杀死了他们。在做了所有这些之后，他向共产党领导人报告说，他确实在农村制造了恐怖，对他来说，这感觉像是一种从未体验过的狂喜。我想知道你是否在现代冲突中看到了同样的复仇中毒模式，
James. Think about what's happening in the Middle East now for many, many years. Do you see the same kinds of patterns? Oh, we certainly do, unfortunately. If we consider Israel and Gaza, for instance, or Russia and Ukraine, all of the language is about revenge seeking. All of the language is about grievance. So one side harms the other. These harms are registered in the brain as incredibly painful. And the desire to retaliate and harm back the other side is ever-present and constant. All the weapons of war that we've created are designed just for revenge gratification. All of the billions of dollars and the enormous technology that's going into them, they're all really objects of abuse if you think about it. We abuse narcotics in the way that we abuse those, but for revenge, we abuse guns, weapons, bombs, tanks, all of it, in order to simply gratify this
詹姆斯。想想中东现在发生的事情，已经很多年了。你看到了同样的模式吗？哦，不幸的是，我们当然看到了。如果我们以以色列和加沙，或者俄罗斯和乌克兰为例，所有的语言都是关于寻求复仇的。所有的语言都是关于委屈的。所以一方伤害另一方。这些伤害在大脑中被记录为极其痛苦。而报复和伤害对方的欲望是无处不在且持续不断的。我们创造的所有战争武器都是为了复仇满足感而设计的。所有投入其中的数十亿美元和巨大的技术，如果你仔细想想，它们都是虐待的对象。我们滥用麻醉品的方式就像我们滥用那些东西一样，但为了复仇，我们滥用枪支、武器、炸弹、坦克，所有这些，只是为了满足这种
unending desire to get pleasure by harming the people who harmed us. The researcher Matthew White has examined mass atrocities down history. You've looked at some of this work and you've interpreted it through the lens of revenge. Tell me what you found, James. So Matthew White has written this enormous book in which he analyzes all of the atrocities in human history, all of the greatest multicides as he calls them, and ranks the top 100, leading to a death toll of about 450 million people in those top 100 atrocities. I went through that list
无休止的通过伤害伤害过我们的人来获得快乐的欲望。研究员马修·怀特（Matthew White）研究了历史上的大规模暴行。你研究过其中一些工作，并从复仇的角度解读了它。告诉我们你发现了什么，詹姆斯。所以马修·怀特写了一本巨大的书，分析了人类历史上的所有暴行，他称之为所有最伟大的“多重杀戮”，并排名前100位，导致这100起暴行中的死亡人数约为4.5亿人。我浏览了那个名单，
and just for the top 20 where most of those deaths occurred, which is about 355 million people killed. And in that group of top 20, all but one of them, in other words, 19, I was able to learn were the result of compulsive revenge seeking in the form of addiction. And this begins with the greatest one, which is World War II with more than 60 million dead, and continues on unrelentingly. But we were able to see that these conflicts, these atrocities, these multicides, all began with some form of perceived grievance or wrongdoing, and then a desire to retaliate and gratification of that, urge to retaliate over and over again, and then the original perpetrator retaliating back, and this going on and on in a conflagration
仅仅是死亡人数发生最多的前20名，大约有3.55亿人死亡。在那前20名中，除了一个之外，换句话说，19个，我了解到是成瘾形式的强迫性复仇寻求的结果。这始于最严重的一个，即第二次世界大战，有超过6000万人死亡，并持续不断。但我们能够看到，这些冲突、这些暴行、这些多重杀戮，都始于某种形式的感知到的委屈或不法行为，然后是报复的欲望和满足那种报复冲动的欲望，一次又一次，然后最初的加害者反过来报复，这种情况持续下去，形成了一场
that can last for years, and as I say, leading to millions of deaths in each one of them. When I think of the current politics of the United States, I hear a significant amount of grievance articulated by various political leaders, people who basically say, you know, we need to take action because these other people have done these terrible things to us. Can you talk a moment about the role of grievance and revenge addiction in modern day countries, including the United States? Sure. In the United States, we're really caught up in this right now. And I think it's because humans are living through a vulnerable period where technology is completely outracing the
可以持续数年的大火，正如我所说，每一场都导致数百万人死亡。当我想到美国当前的政治时，我听到各种政治领导人表达了大量的委屈，人们基本上说，你知道，我们需要采取行动，因为这些人对我们做了这些可怕的事情。你能谈谈委屈和复仇成瘾在现代国家，包括美国的作用吗？当然。在美国，我们现在确实陷入了这种困境。我认为这是因为人类正生活在一个脆弱的时期，技术完全超过了
ability of our brains to keep up with and manage what's happening. So social media networks are playing an enormous role in the grievance revenge cycle that we're experiencing today. These platforms have algorithms that are designed to engage users. But the way that the algorithms do this is by preying upon our desire for revenge and retaliation. So the social media networks enable us to identify and spread grievances at light speed to millions of people. So we can now have millions of people holding the exact same grievance at the same time, multiple times during the day. Politicians have now gotten the idea that they can increase engagement by using these social networks and inflaming these grievances and these desires for revenge. I've sometimes described it as like
我们大脑跟上和管理正在发生的事情的能力。所以社交媒体网络在我们今天经历的委屈-复仇循环中扮演着巨大的角色。这些平台有旨在吸引用户的算法。但算法这样做的方式是利用我们对复仇和报复的渴望。所以社交媒体网络使我们能够以光速向数百万人识别和传播委屈。所以我们现在可以有数百万人同时持有完全相同的委屈，每天多次。政客们现在已经有了想法，他们可以通过使用这些社交网络并煽动这些委屈和复仇欲望来增加参与度。我有时把它描述为像
the COVID epidemic. The disease, the virus, is blowing at us into our faces from our cell phones and our computer screens and we're completely vulnerable to it and have no defense mechanism for it because we've never experienced that before in human history. You say that there's a connection between revenge addiction and the January 6th attack on the US Capitol. How so? Yeah. So that's exactly what I was describing here, right? A group of people led by President Trump who made the false allegation that the election had been stolen by President Biden
新冠疫情。病毒从我们的手机和电脑屏幕上吹向我们的脸，我们对它完全脆弱，没有任何防御机制，因为我们在人类历史上从未经历过这种情况。你说复仇成瘾与1月6日美国国会大厦袭击事件之间存在联系。怎么说？是的。这正是我想在这里描述的，对吧？一群由特朗普总统领导的人，他提出了选举被拜登总统和民主党人窃取的虚假指控。
and Democrats. And they were able very successfully to propagate through this viral experience in social media, to propagate this stop the steal lie. And by doing that, people came to believe that something terrible had gone wrong and they needed to do something about it. And that is to say say retaliate in any way possible. And so a group of them eventually came together, as we know, on January 6th and stormed the Capitol to retaliate for this grievance that had been nurtured for the prior four months. I'm wondering, are all forms of retribution problematic, James? Take the killing of Osama bin Laden, for example, the mastermind of the 9-11 attacks. Would you call that revenge addiction, too?
他们非常成功地通过社交媒体上的这种病毒式传播，传播了“停止窃取”的谎言。通过这样做，人们开始相信发生了可怕的事情，他们需要对此做点什么。也就是说，以任何可能的方式报复。所以正如我们所知，他们中的一群人最终在1月6日聚集在一起，冲进国会大厦，为这种在过去四个月里被培养出来的委屈进行报复。我想知道，所有的报复形式都有问题吗，詹姆斯？以杀死9-11袭击的策划者奥萨马·本·拉登为例。你也会称之为复仇成瘾吗？
I do. You know, it was. He was able to be captured at the time, but instead he was shot and killed. However, the question that you're asking is an important one. Is it in any way at all wrong to kill somebody who is sworn to kill you if you allow them? That's called self-defense, and that is not what grievance and revenge seeking is about. We're talking about grievances of the past that are no longer present, that no longer contain an imminent threat of serious bodily harm or death. To harm or kill someone for that prior grievance when they no longer represent a threat, that is what leads to the violence that we've been describing, and that is the addictive concern that we all need to face. And if public health authorities begin to treat revenge seeking
我称之为。你知道，确实是。他当时是可以被俘虏的，但他却被枪杀了。然而，你问的问题很重要。杀死一个发誓要杀你的人，如果你允许他们的话，这在任何方面都是错误的吗？那叫自卫，那不是委屈和寻求复仇的意义所在。我们谈论的是不再存在的过去委屈，不再包含严重身体伤害或死亡的迫在眉睫的威胁。为了那种过去的委屈而伤害或杀死某人，当他们不再构成威胁时，这就是导致我们所描述的暴力的原因，这就是我们都需要面对的成瘾问题。如果公共卫生当局开始将复仇寻求
for past wrongs as an addiction, we can begin to help people heal from those wrongs and prevent violence. So this is really giving us an opportunity, an unexpected and very important in the course of human history opportunity to prevent violence using public health prevention and treatment strategies that have been used for addiction. We featured the researcher Fred Luskin on hidden brain some time ago and he studies the role of grudges and how we carry around grudges and grievances. And one of the really interesting points that he made that I think echoes and mirrors what you're saying, James, is that the reason to give up a grudge has actually very little to do with the person who has done us harm, that the rationale for doing so is almost
视为一种成瘾，我们就可以开始帮助人们从这些错误中治愈并防止暴力。所以这确实给了我们一个机会，一个在人类历史上意想不到且非常重要的防止暴力的机会，使用已用于成瘾的公共卫生预防和治疗策略。我们前段时间在《隐藏的大脑》中介绍了研究员弗雷德·拉斯金（Fred Luskin），他研究了怨恨的作用以及我们如何背负怨恨和委屈。他提出的一个非常有趣的观点，我认为呼应并反映了你所说的，詹姆斯，那就是放弃怨恨的原因实际上与伤害我们的人几乎没有关系，这样做的理由几乎
entirely self-centered. It actually is good for us to give up grudges rather than being good for the other person. Yeah, and I'm familiar with Dr. Luskin's work, but the neuroscience now that's more recent is bolstering what he's saying. And that neuroscience, as I said, is showing that these key areas of the brain can be quieted and that this intense desire for revenge
完全是以自我为中心的。放弃怨恨实际上对我们有好处，而不是对另一个人有好处。是的，我熟悉拉斯金博士的工作，但现在更新的神经科学正在支持他所说的话。正如我所说，那种神经科学表明，大脑的这些关键区域可以被安静下来，而这种强烈的复仇欲望
along with the intense pain that you're experiencing, all of those things can be turned off by simply imagining forgiveness. And if you imagine it multiple times, you'll eventually come to the conclusion that you'd rather feel better than continue to carry this burden of punishing the person who wronged you.
连同你正在经历的强烈痛苦，所有这些事情都可以通过简单地想象原谅来关闭。如果你多次想象它，你最终会得出结论，你宁愿感觉更好，也不愿继续背负惩罚伤害你的人的负担。
You choose to set yourself free from the pain of the past. And that's available to you through forgiveness. It's not available for revenge, which just lashes you even more tightly to the pain of the past. James, you've looked not just at research studies and brain imaging work, but also the teachings of spiritual and religious leaders. You told me that you were raised in a spiritual household, and in the book you cite the instruction of Jesus who talked about how much we should be willing to forgive.
你选择让自己从过去的痛苦中解脱出来。这可以通过原谅来实现。它不能通过复仇来实现，复仇只会把你更紧地束缚在过去的痛苦中。詹姆斯，你不仅研究了研究报告和大脑成像工作，还研究了精神和宗教领袖的教导。你告诉我你是在一个精神家庭中长大的，在书中你引用了耶稣的教导，他谈到了我们应该多么愿意原谅。
Yeah. When Jesus of Nazareth was asked, how oft shall my brother sin against me and I forgive him till seven times? He responded, I say not unto thee until seven times, but until 70 times seven. So these weren't words, I believe at least, of Jesus telling us how to get ourselves into heaven or how to be a good person or how to obtain the approval of church elders or other people in society. The neuroscience really shows us now that this was extremely practical and scientifically sound advice for preventing violence and restoring peace
是的。当拿撒勒人耶稣被问到：“我兄弟得罪我，我当饶恕他几次呢？到七次可以吗？”他回答说：“我对你说，不是到七次，而是到七十个七次。”所以，我相信这至少不是耶稣告诉我们如何进入天堂，或者如何成为一个好人，或者如何获得教会长老或社会中其他人认可的话。神经科学现在确实向我们表明，这是防止暴力和恢复和平的极其务实且科学合理的建议，
in your own life, in your family, in your community, your society, your nation, and in the world. We just have to follow it. James Kimmel Jr. is a lecturer at Yale University. He's the author of The Science of Revenge, Understanding the World's Deadliest Addiction and How to Overcome It. James, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
在你自己的生活中，在你的家庭、社区、社会、国家和世界中。我们只需要遵循它。詹姆斯·金梅尔是耶鲁大学的讲师。他是《复仇科学：理解世界上最致命的成瘾及其克服方法》的作者。詹姆斯，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。
Thank you, Shankar. HIDDEN BRAIN is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. Do you have a story about a time you took revenge on someone? Or wanted to, but didn't? If you'd be willing to share your stories and follow up questions with James Kimmel Jr. with the Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line revenge.
谢谢你，尚卡尔。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。你有一个关于你向某人复仇的故事吗？或者想过，但没有做？如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享你的故事和给詹姆斯·金梅尔的后续问题，请在你的手机上录制语音备忘录并发送电子邮件至 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。那个电子邮件地址再次是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行“复仇”。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。